وانت تتابع هذه التصريحات للجانب
الاسرائيلي الى جانب الفيديوهات التي
تنشرها كتائب القسام وسرايا
القدس مازال هجار يتحدث عن انجازات وان
كانت هناك تعقيدات كما سماها ما ما
تعليقك ليلى الانجازات حتما هناك الشهداء
الجرحى وحتى ما اطلقت عليه جريده الاردن
الدومو سيد يعني المجزره في الابنيه
والمنازل ولكن اليوم حتى الان وهذا الامر
اصبح واضحا ما نشرته اليوم جريده نيويورك
تايمز نقلا عن بعض القاده العسكريين الذين
يقولون ان هناك تناقض بين الاهداف هي
متناقضه مع بعضها على سبيل المثال تحرير
الرهائن وتدمير حماس هذا الامر يتناقض مع
بعضه البعض لانه تدمير حماس اذا صح قد
يدمر الرهائن
اليوم ما يعكسه الواقع الميداني التكتيكي
ليلى هذا امر مهم جدا هو الاساس يعني
اليوم عندما يكون هناك تفوق تكتيكي عندما
يكون هناك تفوق نوعي وتقني لدى اسرائيل
يجب خلق ما
يسمى بالتعديلات والابتكارات التكتيكيه
لضرب هذا التفوق وهذا الامر لدى المقاومه
منظومه متكامله يعني عندما نتحدث عن
القناص عندما نتحدث عن الشواظ عندما نتحدث
عن الكمائن التي بي جي الياسين 105 هي
منظومه تستعمل من ضمن عقيده عسكريه لزياده
القتلى والاستنزاف لدى القيادات لدى جيش
الاحتلال وبالتالي هذه التراكمات قد تؤدي
الى تغيير سياسي عند الاسرائيليين لكن
عناد نتنياهو والبعد السياسي خلق مشكله
سياسيه وخلق مشكله سياسيه بين ط ط بات
السياسيين من العسكر وعدم قدره العسكر على
تحقيق هذه الاهداف هذا امر مهم جدا اليوم
هذه الصوره الاستراتيجيه الكبرى تنطلق من
التكتيك ولكن عندما نتحدث عن العسكر هل
نتحدث عنه ككتله واحده متفقه بمعنى عندما
نقلت النيويورك تايمز عن المسؤولين
العسكريين الاسرائيليين هذا الكلام ثم
نفاه هجار قائلا انه لا يمثل ما يقوله
الجيش او ما يقف عنده الجيش الى اي حد
هناك شرخ ربما في المؤسسه العسكريه بدا
يظهر بصوره يمكن ان تنعكس على
الميدان هناك شرخ بسبب الخسائر
بسبب البعد النفسي لدى العديد من الجنود
العسكر وبالتالي بسبب ال الرهائن والاسرى
ولكن ليلى قد يكون هو تسريب من العسكر الى
النيويورك تايمز مقصودا الا نتذكر كيف منع
نتنياهو دخول رئيس الاركان
بعد قبل تفتيشه لكي لا يكون هناك جهاز
تسجيل او تنسد ال الشرخ واقع قد يكون هذا
الامر تسريب معين بالاضافه الى ان تصريح
هاليفي عندما قال نطلب من القياده
السياسيه ان تحدد مرحله ما بعد غزه كي
نعرف كيف نقيس
النجاح والى اي مدى يجب الذهاب بالامر
العسكري هذا امر اصبح معروف ليلى هذه نقطه
مهمه وخصوصا ان الجانب الاسرائيلي اللي
يعني فعلا يمارس هذه التسريبات وشاهدنا
امثله كثيره لها وربما هذا الاشتباك
بالايدي الذي تم الحديث عنه بين وزير
الدفاع او ما قد يصل الى ذلك يعني هو لم
يحصل ولكن كان خلافا
كبيرا الان المعركه والطريقه التي تدار
فيها التركيز على الشمال من جديد ما
تعليقك على هذه
النقطه
الاسرائيلي او جيش الاحتلال يريد الانتقال
بسرعه في الوسط وفي جنوب القطاع الى حاله
المرحله الثالثه كما يدعي انه حققها في
شمال القطاع لماذا لانه يريد ان يفرض امرا
واقعا يصبح الامر روتيني فيه يرضي
الامريكيين يرضي الداخل يمكنه اعاده
المستوطنات الى الغلاف ولكن يبقى العقده
الاساسيه وهذا ايضا كتبته نيويورك تايمز
لى الصواريخ التي تلغي اي انجاز وموضوع
الانفاق الذي سيسمح للمقاومه بليونه
وانسيابيه كامله لاعاده خوض حرب ما يسمى
بحرب العصابات وهذا ما يحصل في الشيخ
رضوان وهذا ما يخس في جباليا وهذا ما يخسر
في حي الزيتون في الدرج هذه الامور هو
عمليه الاستنزاف ربح الوقت مقابل اعطاء
المساحه والاستنزاف الوقت يلعب ضد اسرائيل